lost civilizations
mysterious sunken cities
and legendary atlantis itself
vanished beneath the waves
there is a huge amount of
unrecorded human history beneath the
ocean surface
that we don't know very much about at
all
imagine if we could empty the oceans
letting the water drain away to reveal
the secrets of the sea floor
now we can
using the latest underwater technology
[Music]
piercing the deep oceans
and turning accurate data into 3d images
is this a huge underwater temple carved
by a mysterious lost civilization
why are these perfectly circular stones
lying at the bottom of a bay in the
aegean sea there are shapes on the
seabed that just don't make sense are
these just rocks
or the remains of an ancient city
parts of this are just beginning to be
revealed for the first time
wow
and is the real sight of atlantis
finally about to be revealed people want
to believe in places like atlantis they
want to believe in other worlds
[Applause]
stories of sunken cities have fascinated
for millennia
the most tantalizing of all
atlantis
first described by ancient philosopher
plato
a dazzling civilization
destroyed by the gods as punishment for
human pride
[Music]
people connect to that story and it's
because of this idea of an ancient
civilization a utopia that we've evolved
from
two thousand years later the idea of
atlantis continues to fascinate a-list
archaeologists
and the producers of b-list movies
atlantis is the story of those who like
today would use the marvels of science
to conquer and enslave atlantis a world
that worshipped strange gods of science
a science gone berserk
would have loved us okay he would have
had a great time he would have said at
last you know people are listening to me
people are taking my story seriously and
he would have he would have enjoyed this
immensely
using science not science fiction
draining the oceans exposes new evidence
about atlantis and other stories of
great sunken cities around the world
as the waters recede from around the
remote japanese island of yanaguni
a mysterious formation begins to appear
could it be the creation of an advanced
ancient people
[Music]
yanaguni lies in the east china sea
the waters here are perilous
schools of hammerhead sharks patrol amid
powerful currents
typhoons frequently battered the island
for divers
it's the ultimate challenge
kiachiro arataki is one of the pioneers
of diving
[Music]
i felt as if i were looking down into
the seabed from the sky
searching for a new dive site he makes a
startling discovery
i
i thought for a moment it was similar to
the machu picchu wings
it's an extraordinary spectacle
the size of five football fields
smooth-sided walls rise up to the summit
the height of an eight-story building
flights of stone steps climb up from the
base
and on every side the shapes and forms
are strikingly regular
it can't be formed naturally without
human involvement it couldn't be like
that so
what could it be
it's impossible to investigate the
structure fully by diving
[Music]
the only way is to conduct a survey
using the latest scanning technology
although the shallow waters around the
yonanguni island are close to human
habitation we don't know much about them
that's an unknown frontier
using sonar scans hironobu can records a
complete digital map of the seafloor
using this data it's possible for the
very first time
to drain away the waters
and reveal what lies beneath in exact
detail
the summit of the mysterious structure
begins to appear
water pours off its smooth terraced
layers
exposing them once again to the sky
and with the monument left high and dry
its true scale becomes clear
fast
imposing
and spectacular
the incredible discovery attracts
worldwide attention
divers journalists and tv crews flock to
yanaguni
all asking what could this mysterious
structure be
and scientists come here too
among them is professor masaki kimura
one of japan's top marine geologists
when i dived underwater to explore it i
felt right away that it must be a
man-made structure
he finds several features that he
believes
here you see something that looks like
the front gate of a castle it's like a
tunnel and you go through it
on the far side of the tunnel a road
loops around to a flight of steps
watched over by two mysterious stone
objects
here and here and if you look at them
you will find turtles with their necks
extended on both sides according to
ancient japanese folklore the dragon god
ryujin lives in an underwater palace
watched over by turtles
to professor kimura
this indicates that the monument is so
important it needs guarding
and that's not all
if you go up this path you get to this
place
this portion is triangular that's why
it's called the triangle pool
since this very big and shallow as well
you can relax in it
also the sea surface is very close to it
and it's warm due to the sunlight
you feel chilly after you come out of
the deeper area down there and you can
warm up here
but the monument's most striking feature
is its wide flat terraces large enough
to support thousands of people
professor kimura believes the gateway
stairs
turtles and terraces
all point towards one purpose
i think they used it as a castle
[Music]
but to prove his theory professor kimura
needs more
the artifacts of those who once lived
here
he scours the structure looking for
clues and discovers what looks like
primitive tools
then hidden behind one of the great
walls the most remarkable find of all
look at this a symbol is inscribed here
and here's a whole probably they hang
this article like this and here's
something looking like a letter maybe it
could be a kind of talisman to protect
people from evil for professor kimura
the case is closed the artifacts and the
monuments regular shapes prove that
humans lived here 8 000 years ago
after that rising sea levels claimed the
territory of this lost race of master
builders but is that the real story of
yanaguni
professor kimura believes that this
extraordinary structure off the coast of
japan is a gigantic castle
built long before the pyramids of egypt
by a mysterious lost civilization
but
is it
with the water drained away it's
possible to scrutinize the monument in
forensic detail
the edges appear regular and straight as
if made from blocks carved by human hand
but closer examination reveals something
else
the surfaces are smooth and unbroken
the monument is not assembled from
handmade blocks
but is in fact
one solid mass of rock
okiku
the pyramid area and the headland behind
it are connected with each other the
surface of the terrain has a lot of
grooves so you may think they're
separate but since they consist of the
identical stone they are originally
connected
the basic form of the monument is
clearly natural
but what about the gateway steps turtles
and pool
[Music]
could it be that an ancient people
carved into this huge rock transforming
it into a great castle or temple
[Music]
studying the headland on shore provides
the answer
the shapes here are strikingly similar
to those found on the monument and
that's because they were formed in
exactly the same way
both are made of sandstone which when
subjected to stress such as during an
earthquake can fracture along vertical
faults forming angular shapes and what
look like steps
put something like that under water have
the water wash over the top of it and
clear away all the debris and you've got
very very fine step-like structures but
they're no more
human-made than any other structure down
there
the lack of tool marks is further
confirmation
the forces which shaped this remarkable
place
are geological
but what of the artifacts perhaps the
monument if not built by ancient people
was inhabited by them
walking these steps
crowding these natural
terraces but so far
no other objects have been found
suggesting that the talisman and tools
were dropped from a boat passing
overhead landing on the monument
simply by chance
[Music]
clear thing for yanaguni for me is
there's no pottery there's no evidence
of actual human occupation there's not a
single wall from the site
there's there's nothing on it that
indicates human activity
[Music]
the yanaguni monument is an
extraordinary natural formation
created by epic geological forces
but its shapes appear so regular that
many still believe it holds a secret
ancient purpose
you can take that leap if you have an
imagination and say yes this could be
an ancient city beneath the sea but in
the case of yanaguni i'm in those ranks
that feel that it's not it's geology we
want to believe that science doesn't
have all the answers we want to believe
innately that there is something out
there that we can connect with
spiritually and that hasn't really been
polluted by being the subject of
scientific discovery
and still among the believers is
professor kimura
he remains convinced that the monument
was inhabited by his ancestors
and continues to search for evidence to
prove the doubters wrong
[Music]
beneath the oceans of the world lie many
more tantalizing traces of possible lost
civilizations
as the water continues to drain away in
the eastern mediterranean
astonishing structures emerge in a quiet
island harbor
is this jumble of shaped stones the
architectural debris of a once great
city
alicanna's bay
a tourist hot spot on the island of
zakinthos greece
diver pavlos vutos sets out to take some
underwater photos
i went in the water to make photographs
general photographs a face of weight of
things in the bottom rocks formations
things
pavlos swims farther out into the bay in
search of clearer water
then
out of the gloom
he sees something that will change his
life
it was really strange
they don't look like the rocks at the
harbour or the rocks at the beach
it's something really unique because it
looks like man-made
the debris stretches out for hundreds of
yards in all directions
the area is so large that pavlos is
convinced he's found the remains of an
entire town
they are too many different shaped
stones
they look like pavement or like
walls that have fallen down and breaking
pieces but definitely
they don't look natural
but i was dreaming of palace and temples
and unseen life
it was an amazing find
the discovery sends a bolt of
electricity through the world of
archaeology
professor michael stamatakis immediately
travels to zachenthos to investigate
when they sent me
initially some photographs i have to say
that i was confused and i thought that
they probably are
some man-made products
stamitakis recalls seeing similar shapes
on land
at the site of an ancient settlement
built over 2 000 years ago
you see the
the carving here
looks like
and also the other
so we have some findings in malikanas in
this size small one but long
and narrow
if the same shapes lie on the seabed
they could indicate an ancient
settlement just offshore concealed under
the bay and forgotten about for
centuries
if you show in any scientist this
photograph and also a photograph of
malikana say that's the same they say
okay
comparing the images is not enough
the only way to reveal a complete
picture of the structures is a detailed
underwater survey
simon brown is an expert in 3d modeling
but the task facing him
is immense
right now we're not quite sure how big
the area is i've estimated it's about 16
acres
which will be more than double the
largest subject i've ever covered to
date
it's a weird place
there's definitely
features here
that i've never seen anywhere else
before
they look out of place
but then i started to see more
regular shapes that look like cut stone
so
my mind then starts to think is it
is it man-made
can draining the waters of the
mediterranean provide the answer
simon brown is mapping mysterious
underwater structures discovered in a
greek bay
could they be the remains of an ancient
town
he takes nearly 4 000 high-resolution
photographs of the sea floor
tracking each with pinpoint accuracy
through gps
using these images it's now possible to
do something which has never been done
before
drain the waters of alicanna's bay and
reveal for the first time ever a 3d plan
of the entire sea floor
as the mediterranean begins to recede
a world is exposed that's been invisible
for thousands of years
first
the rocky shoreline is left high and dry
then
from the dark depths
regular shapes begin to appear
hidden among the rocks
could they be the bases of stone columns
which together once formed a grand
colonnade
the use of colonnades is a turning point
in ancient greek architecture
builders can now switch from wood to
stone a far stronger material to create
ever larger temples to the gods
a colonnade in alecanus bay would prove
that an important ancient settlement
once stood here
but some experts remain skeptical there
are structures all over the world that
mimic something that humans may have
created doesn't mean that humans created
them
with the water drained away
it's now possible to search the seabed
for evidence of human occupation
fragments of the pots people cooked with
charcoal from their fires
tools for farming and weapons for
defending their homes
any objects made of metal clay or stone
should have survived
but
there's nothing
which means these extraordinary remains
whatever they are
are not the relics of a lost town
so what are they
[Music]
the first approach was to see the
material not only from pictures but to
touch it
it's very soft it's not easy to to
assume you can make a building with this
very soft material the so-called bases
of the columns are composed of this soft
material so
this material is just a little hardened
mud it's nothing more it's like
the material we have in the cliff
further analysis reveals the formations
are what geologists call concretions
solid blocks of sedimentary rock formed
by powerful volcanic activity
underwater vents release methane from
deep within the earth combining with
microbes and sediment the methane causes
regular circular shapes to form
far from being a relic of ancient greece
the structures here predate human
activities by 5 million years
despite all the evidence against his
theory pavlos vutos remains convinced
that the fantastical landscape he
discovered was shaped by his ancestors i
don't know if there was a palace
some temples storages or just houses
this is for the scientists to find
what i see
is signs
of civilization
classical civilizations dominate the
mediterranean for over a thousand years
today
all around its coast
people tell stories of sunken cities
as the waters around greece drain away
further an extraordinary underwater
vista is exposed
could these patterns on the seafloor
be remnants of an ancient city
the village of elephones
sits on a small island just off the
greek coast
at first glance an ordinary fishing port
but in 1967 less than a hundred yards
out to sea something attracts the
attention of a visiting maritime
archaeologist
snorkeling in 13 feet of water nicholas
fleming catches a glimpse of regular
shapes on the seafloor
then exploring deeper he sees what he
thinks is evidence of human activity i
looked at these rows of stones and i i
just had no idea what it was but i
realized immediately
that it was man-made
that we were looking at a large part of
a town
and i mean i just went crazy
fleming is convinced he has found
something special
but could these simply be natural
formations mimicking human structures
like the concretions of nearby alacanus
bay
the following year fleming returns with
a team of surveyors to discover the
truth
using tape measures they document what
they find
and the results
are astonishing
the site is strewn with signs of human
activity
pots storage vessels and tools lie
across a huge area of the seabed
there can be no doubt fleming has
discovered the remains of an ancient
town
it's named pavlopetri after a nearby
island
but who built it
these questions inspire a generation of
archaeologists
well i've always been interested in
submerged settlements um summer's towns
and i'd read about pavlo peche as a boy
and this idea of an intact prehistoric
town underwater just seemed you know
incredibly romantic incredibly exciting
henderson can now fulfill a childhood
dream
and explore this haunted underwater
world for himself and here we have a
coherent stone there you can see it's
got a very concave
concave surface there that's for
grinding
ground whatever it was that you were
turning into you know flower
[Music]
that's quite clear after fact very nice
[Music]
there is a huge amphora one amphora
two amphara
three
four five
this gives you an example of what's
coming out of the sand what's the
rotating out of the sound like that's
the base of an amphora
there's the amphora shape there it's on
its side
there's another one next to it and
another one there
and further into the bay
more evidence of human life
and death
so here's assist grave
edge set slabs
a very small one
possibly for a baby
there are about 40 of these on the site
diving gives intriguing glimpses of
objects lying upon the seabed
but it's impossible to gain a complete
picture
to do this it must be mapped with the
latest in underwater scanning technology
using this data
it's now possible to drain away the
waters above pavlo petri
and bring sunlight back to a forgotten
world
and a true
sunken city
with the entire bay drained away
everything becomes clear
the lines are the foundations of
buildings laid out in clear streets
at the heart of the town is a large open
area
perhaps an ancient marketplace
and nearby
the remnants of a huge structure perhaps
an important civic building
the remains covered 20 acres and the
town could have housed 4 000 people
a thriving ancient settlement
once existed here
the next challenge
is to discover
who built it
and when
we know how old the occupation of the
site is because we've got pottery
and pottery particularly this part of
the world is very well dated
what was really exciting is we actually
found evidence for poetry from the end
of the stone age
so we've actually got occupation here
from about 5 500 years ago and then
we've got every single bit of pottery
you would expect up to about 1100 bc
there's no gaps in that so the place
seems to have been continuously occupied
throughout the bronze age
pavlo petri was occupied for 2 400 years
during a revolutionary period of human
development
at its peak in the bronze age around
1700 bc
it looked like this
a perfect example of the time when
europeans start to live in stone-built
towns with regular laid out streets
but one question remains
why did the builders of this town choose
this particular location in a remote
part of ancient greece
exploring the drained landscape around
the ancient city reveals an
all-important clue
at its edge a huge sandbag stretches out
into the ocean during the bronze age
people don't build ports out of stone
they bring ships up to the shore and
then beach them
and pavlo petri's location
means it can exploit the trade routes
that boom during the bronze age across
the mediterranean
evidence of early commercial activity is
everywhere
the interesting thing is we've clearly
got a lot of material coming in we've
found thousands and thousands of shares
of very large storage vessels which have
been using it for storing um olive oil
wine that kind of thing and generally
anything they were like the containers
of the day
and that's not all
pavlo petri is also a hub for
manufacturing
we've got a lot of evidence for um loom
weights
thousands of loom weights way more than
you would need for domestic production
so it seems like maybe textiles was
something that were being produced on
the site and perhaps exported
pavlo petri is an extraordinary bustling
vibrant port city
and an important center of trade
so how did such an advanced metropolis
meet its end
an ancient submerged city off the coast
of greece
how it came to lie on the sea floor is a
mystery
one of the interesting things about
pavlo petri and its submergence is
there's actually no historical
references to it at all it sunk into the
waves and then it was out of sight out
of mind and there's certainly no
classical sources that refer to its
sinking and there's nothing until it's
discovery really in the 20th century
scanning the drained bay
could reveal what happened to pavlo
petri
at the edge of the town it's possible to
make out three mysterious lines
these are strips of beach rock formed by
the action of sunlight on salt water
they form only near the shoreline
it can mean only one thing
earthquakes caused this land to subside
into the sea
so there was a big earthquake perhaps
part part of the remains went under the
water and part of them were still
surviving then there was another
earthquake it was pushed under then
there was a third
and it was gone
pavlo petri is one of the most important
bronze age sites in the world
and the oldest submerged town ever
discovered
but it's not alone
[Music]
a lot of the major finds in the next
couple of decades are going to come from
the sea i think we have the potential to
to rewrite what we know about human
history
pavlo petri is an extraordinary find
but it is not the legendary atlantis
various locations for plato's dazzling
city have been proposed around the world
but most academic investigations point
to one place the mediterranean
as its waters continue to drain away at
its western end
new and tantalizing evidence is revealed
could archaeologists finally have found
the site of plato's famous lost city
mark glitcher is a geophysicist
long fascinated by plato's story i do
think that becoming interested in
atlantis can be almost like a a bug or
an infection or like gambling i think
one can become obsessed
plato wrote about atlantis in 360 bc
describing an advanced metropolis 9 000
years before his own time
lost beneath the waves in a cataclysmic
event
mark gutcher has analyzed plato's texts
searching for clues to its location
this power came forth out of the
atlantic ocean from an island situated
in front of the straits which are by you
called the pilars of heracles
the pillars of heracles is the name
given by plato to the maritime boundary
of the ancient greek world
many locations have been suggested
but mark believes he has the answer the
straits of gibraltar
so here at cape's partel we're at the
northern edge of the moroccan atlantic
coast and just at the entrance to the
straits of gibraltar about 10 to 15
kilometers off to the northwest there's
a submerged bank
some people have suggested that it might
have been inhabited and it might have
formed the
origin of the atlantis legend
today
this area sits under the second busiest
shipping route in the world a difficult
place for sub-sea investigation
during a project to study rising sea
levels here mark gets his chance
[Music]
using a remotely operated vehicle or rov
he sets out to map the sea floor
[Music]
it's challenging work
it was very difficult both the towing of
the camera was difficult keeping the
ship in place was difficult and
especially trying to keep the rov in
place was really really difficult
finally
mark gets the sonar scanning data that
he needs
now combining this information with the
latest computer graphics
it's possible to drain away the seawater
from between the ancient pillars of
heracles
and attempt to solve one of the greatest
archaeological mysteries of all time
soon
rocks begin to emerge
and the unmistakable outline of an
island gradually appears
is this the site of atlantis
exposed for the first time in 11 000
years
once again important clues lie in
plato's own writing
plato says that the city and all of its
war-like men were destroyed in one day
and night of terrible misfortune
caused by strong earthquakes and floods
the island revealed by draining the
ocean sits on a subduction zone a
boundary between the huge tectonic
plates that make up the earth's surface
the exact point where the biggest
earthquakes strike
a series of powerful earthquakes and
tsunamis could have obliterated atlantis
and sent the island on which it rests
down into the ocean depths you could
imagine
that during great earthquakes there
might have been some subsidence so if we
were to take into account maybe
20 or 30 meters of subsidence due to
those earthquakes uh there might have
been a somewhat larger island there
the geology supports plato's account of
the destruction of atlantis
but one other vital piece of evidence is
still needed
draining the ocean has revealed a
mysterious island exactly where plato
said atlantis would be but one other
piece of evidence must be present for it
actually to be atlantis the remains of
substantial man-made structures using
the drained landscape it's possible to
study the island's surface in
extraordinary three-dimensional detail
searching carefully for the remains of
walls temples bridges and anything
constructed by human hands
but there are none
nowhere on this mysterious island are
there any lines or geometric shapes
which would indicate the presence of a
great ancient city
atlantis did not exist in the tiny
island of spartel
if it did exist traces of it have not
yet been found
however the story of this submerged
island is not over yet there may be no
trace of a city built out of stone but
evidence found on land nearby
suggests that during the stone age when
sea levels were much lower people did
live here and in many other places just
like it and during this period our human
ancestors make some of the most
important breakthroughs of all time
they learn how to farm keep domesticated
animals use sophisticated tools build
wooden houses and begin to trade
then
the last ice age comes to an end
[Music]
over the course of 15 000 years
sea levels rise by 400 feet
and the territory of these early people
vanishes
their tools homes and weapons are washed
away
that elemental human story may help
explain the timeless appeal of the
atlantis legend
there are many many stories out there in
the world that recall times when land
that was once inhabited was submerged
did that information inform plato's
fiction about atlantis
i think there's no doubt that almost
every culture in the world has a flood
myth a deluge story because we developed
as a species within this period of
rising sea level so that for me is so
fundamental to understanding ourselves
as a species that we should be looking
into this
plato's story of atlantis is about human
folly
and the destructive power of nature
today
the rising level of the oceans threatens
all coastal communities
great port cities like bangkok ho chi
minh city and dhaka are all at risk
and in north america there's one of
particular concern
new orleans
sitting on the banks of the great
mississippi river
the city's average height is six feet
below sea level this makes it highly
vulnerable to flooding
in 2005 disaster strikes
hurricane katrina causes a massive storm
surge and the levees designed to protect
the city are breached
the resulting floods
are catastrophic
nearly 2 000 people die and many more
are left homeless
and the situation in new orleans is
getting worse
because the city itself is sinking
due in part to the removal of
groundwater some districts of new
orleans are subsiding by two inches a
year given ongoing sea level rise which
is the scientific fact
the time will come when some of our
settlements and our time are underwater
cities like new orleans they all have
suffered incursions of water and the
time will come
when we will no longer be able to battle
that incursion
by the turn of the next century
new orleans could be uninhabitable
a mysterious underwater city
studied by maritime archaeologists
a modern day
atlantis
[Music]
you